en este vídeo quiero ver si puedo probar
más resultados interesantes acerca de
las matrices transpuestas y bueno vamos
a comenzar considerando una matriz ce
que va a ser la suma de otras dos
matrices a y b así que se es igual a b a
y b tienen que tener la misma dimensión
para que la suma está bien definida y se
va a tener la misma dimensión que a y
que ve pero bueno tienes una entrada
típica en la matriz sé quién es la
entrada y j de la matriz se vamos a
derrotarla por 6 j pues la suma de las
matrices la definimos como la matriz que
se obtiene sumando las columnas de a con
las columnas correspondientes de b
así que la primera columna ese sería la
primera columna de además la primera
columna debe etcétera pero eso se reduce
a sumar las matrices entrada entrada así
que si hay jota es la entrada en la en
el décimo renglón y la hotte sima
columna de a entonces se y j se obtiene
como ay j
y j donde lógicamente b y j es la
entrada que está en el vigésimo renglón
hijo teshima columna debe ok
ahora qué pasa si comienzo a pensar en
las trans puestas vamos a suponer que la
matriz a la matriz se ve algo así es la
matriz cuyas entradas tienen la forma
hay j no voy a escribir todas las
entradas porque me tardo muchísimo
tiempo así que bien la matriz a se ve
algo así como se ve su transpuesta pues
vamos a decir que la transporta tiene
entradas
a prima y j esta prima va a denotar que
estoy trabajando en la transporta y
ahora bien la transpuesta que es pues es
el resultado de intercambiar los
renglones y las columnas de a así que
esta entrada que aquí está en la
posición y jota que estaría en el mismo
lugar que ésta no es igual a esta en
general no es igual no tiene por qué ser
igual en si esta entrada se obtiene
se obtiene intercambiando los renglones
y las columnas de así que la entrada en
la transporta que está en la posición y
jota se corresponde con la entrada que
está en la posición j y en la matriz
original se correspondería digamos con
esta entrada de aquí
no tiene por qué ser igual a esta pero
si es igual a esta de acá estas dos son
iguales ok y el mismo argumento lo puedo
aplicar para ver vamos a decir que b
transpuesta
es igual a la matriz
a la matriz cuyas entradas son de i j
prima así que es exactamente lo mismo la
prima de nota a la trans presta estoy
trabajando con entradas de la trans
puesta y quiénes son las entradas de
beta print debe prima quien es b y jota
prima pues de nuevo de y j prima va a
sencillamente ser de jota y donde bj y
es la entrada de la matriz b así que
bueno si tuviera aquí la entrada en la
matriz transpuesta que está en la en el
segundo renglón tercera columna entonces
esa vendría de la entrada que está en el
tercer renglón segunda columna pero
bueno vamos a regresar a este problema
vamos a suponer que se transporta es de
nuevo la matriz que se ve algo así sus
entradas son de la forma se prima y j
y j por qué
esa es ser transpuesta
ahora bien qué forma tiene se prima y j
pues sí está en nuestras puestas así
como lo hicimos acá se prima y jota es
lo mismo que se j y ok y esto tienes
pues esto nosotros sabemos de aquí que
se j y es lo mismo que a j
más de jota y es como si esto fuera una
ecuación con incógnitas xy ya digamos es
x es igual a x v x y xi aki sustituyó x
x j
deport y entonces obtengo aj y bj ok y
esto a su vez quienes pues yo sé que acá
arriba yo sé
aj allí es lo mismo que hay jota prima
prima prima y j
y bj y es lo mismo que ve prima y j de
prima y j pero quiénes son estos
nosotros ahora sabemos que esto de aquí
esto son las entradas de este transporte
así que tengo que ser transpuesta que es
lo mismo que a más b transpuesta es
igual a más b transpuesta tiene entradas
iguales a la suma de las entradas de la
matriz a transpuesta con las de la
matriz b transpuesta
así que esto de aquí es en realidad a
traspuesta más b transpuesta así que
tenemos un gran signo igual aquí
tomar la transpuesta de la suma de
matrices equivale a primero transponer y
después sumar así que este resultado es
bastante interesante vamos a hacer otro
resultado bien pues qué pasa ahora si
consideramos esto ya esa parte si
consideramos que a la menos uno
a la inversa la matriz inversa versa
y recuerden que quiere decir que una
matriz ya la matriz inversa de otra pues
esto quiere decir que a la menos uno por
a es igual a la matriz identidad de las
dimensiones de a a tiene que ser una
matriz cuadrada y la identidad tiene que
tener las mismas dimensiones y además
también quiere decir que a por la
inversa por al menos uno también es la
matriz identidad
recuerden que estas dos cosas el
producto de matrices no es conmutativo
así que estas dos cosas podrían ser
diferentes
ok dado eso
dado eso qué pasa si atrás pongo si
atrás pongo estas dos ecuaciones por
ejemplo si tomo esta isla atrás pongo
obtengo que a la menos uno por a
transpuesta debe ser igual a la
identidad transpuesta pero quién es la
identidad transpuesta vamos a ver la
identidad quién es pues la identidad de
n por n es la matriz que tiene unos en
la diagonal tiene puros uno sobre la
diagonal y ceros en todos los demás
lugares pero aquí 0 acá así que si la
trans pongo e intercambio renglones por
columnas lo único que estoy haciendo es
intercambiando ceros porque todo lo que
está sobre la diagonal se queda igual
sólo estoy cambiando este 0 por este 0
pero en si los unos se quedan igual así
que la respuesta de la identidad la
transpuesta de la identidad es la
identidad por otro lado yo sé que esto
de aquí la transpuesta de un producto es
el producto de los factores tras puestos
pero con orden invertido así que esto
sería
sería transpuesta por al menos 1
transpuesta y eso me da la identidad
pero si yo ahora tomo está en esta
ecuación de aquí y la atrás pongo que
obtendría pues obtendría
por al menos 1 transpuesta es igual a la
identidad transpuesta que es igual a la
identidad pero quienes estoy aquí de
nuevo esto sería
a al menos 1 transpuesta por a
transpuesta
en otras palabras qué implica esto
que puedo deducir de todo esto de aquí
pues
estas dos cosas juntas me implican que
a al menos 1 transpuesta
es la inversa
d
transpuesta u otro modo de escribir esto
es a la menos 1 transpuesta es igual a a
transpuesta a la menos 1 es decir la
inversa de la matriz transpuesta es
sencillamente la transpuesta de la
matriz inversa de la matriz original así
que este resultado también es bastante
interesante